TMG had a report on Saturday that on
Friday night dak Prescott had a party at
his home for a friend that at one point
up to 30 people attended there's a zq
elliott attending the party allegedly
there are other photos that make it
clear there was a lot of food there even
more than Ezekiel Elliott could eat and
there was a photo of a table that was
set for dinner at this party that was
not going to entail people being at
least six feet apart there's a
stay-at-home order in Texas and a police
officer reportedly showed up to look
into the situation but in prosper Texas
they are relying upon voluntary
compliance with stay at home orders
that's part of the story at the Fort
Worth star-telegram which made it
obvious that Officer wasn't going to do
anything to aggressively investigate
whether or not there was a violation but
based upon the TMZ report there was a
violation based upon the TMZ report
thirty people were attacked Prescott's
house on a Friday night and Chris this
is infuriating if it's true at a time
when people are across the country
taking this seriously in order to limit
the spread and if this was people
driving around on motorcycles without
helmets or doing other reckless behavior
that only affected them I could care
less but this is reckless behavior that
potentially contributes to the spread of
a virus that is killing people and again
as I said a few minutes ago why is this
controversial that we should want people
to comply with the stay at home orders
so we can get through this I mean if
there's no football season this year one
of the reasons is gonna be we didn't get
the virus under control one of the
reason we get the virus under control is
because people weren't properly staying
at home and compliance with these orders
why is this why is this so hard for
people to figure out Chris help me well
yeah I don't know why Mike you know
honestly this is why you're kind of boss
about your job first off you're just not
afraid to call people out when guys do
things that are they're wrong like this
you know most people in your position or
you know honestly they're worried about
oh no dak Prescott might never come on
my program again or you might never do
an interview with me so no one's gonna
call him out or anybody else out for you
know the negative the look it gives to
the rest of society and I'm with you I
don't understand that
now I also don't understand like you
know with these rules why doesn't stapes
and force them a little more strictly
and tightly I feel like you know I hear
a few stories every day on social media
about people getting together this way
but I don't understand it I don't
especially you know I won I don't
understand getting together - if you're
gonna have this type of get-together you
know I would just think hey keep
everybody's cell phone you got to take
it when they walk in the door why would
you let anybody take pictures you know
somebody at that party here you trusted
and invited dak Prescott took pictures
and sent it to TMZ I mean that's messed
up but but Chris Chris what right it is
the height of stupid dog trouble right
people are violating these orders and
then sending the images out on social
media deliberately like Dez Bryant did
during his multiple workouts with dak
Prescott this was someone who was there
who made the information available to
TMZ who contacted the police department
and to them I say good this is the kind
of stuff that needs to be addressed and
I'm continue to be astounded that it is
controversial and if you look around on
Twitter there's a lot of people out
there who either completely fail to
understand how this virus works maybe
they're still under the influence of all
the horrible information that was put
out there but well definitely right yes
right I mean that's got to be part of it
I mean people were misinformed I mean
people were misinformed until really
just about 10 10 days ago two weeks ago
we were still hearing wrong information
on the subject so if you're a young kid
like doc Prescott and I mean I don't
mean that to be like derogatory I'm just
saying the guy that's in his mid-20s and
when I was in my mid-20s I was a
sometimes look at the news type of guy
you caught the news last week or ten
days ago you might not think it's as
crucial you might not even know some of
these rules but Myka this is what this
is one thing I'll say to Mike this is
why I think you know and again I'm not
saying I would have been much different
from dak Prescott I'm not trying to
judge him you know I was an idiot who
thought I was
you know nothing could stop me either
and I hope these people were at the
party are not going to see their
grandmothers and fathers and things like
that I hope they're you know at least
saying and somewhat isolation once they
leave these parties but this is to me
reasons why I think you could have an
NFL football season this year because I
don't think NFL players care all that
much they care about others and loved
ones but I think most NFL players and I
just know myself at the age of 24 and 25
at 20 I thought I was indestructible and
I would probably be sitting here at home
right now telling my wife like screw
Kovan 19 I want to play football this
year this is what I'm here to do and I
would bet you that the majority of the
NFL is like that now coming up with a
program to make it happen is crazy but
it shows you the mindset of the player
is all I'm saying Mike that's the core
of the problem Chris I remember being
that age and yeah it would have seized
upon any justification to continue to
live my life the way I wanted to live my
life right you're only young once and if
you've got people in high political
office or people who have major
platforms on social media radio or
elsewhere telling you this is no big
deal you grab onto that if you want to
justify living life the way you want to
live it and you can say to yourself and
anyone who calls you out on it
so-and-so says it's no big deal
so-and-so says it's just the flu
so-and-so says it's a creation of the
media and it's all overblown not because
you're taking a political stance but
because you want to do what you want to
do and I'd have been the same damn way
and I would have needed somebody to
reach through the camera and grab me by
the shirt and say stop being a damn fool
and that's what I'm trying to do because
these people are being damn fools
influenced by even bigger fools who
should know better when they downplayed
this back in February January in March
all right well yes yes yes to all of
that and then you know I just wondered
too with the social media pictures last
week in dak Prescott and Dez Bryant and
them at the gym and you know a little
bit of an uproar as far as that was
considered I mean did the Jones family
call back
did they tell him at least hey let's not
do this this is not a good look and he
still threw this party I don't know but
I would hope that somebody is getting in
the ear of dak Prescott and hopefully
from here on out because I don't think
doc Prescott is a bad guy you've been
around him I know either I don't need a
good guy sometimes good people do stupid
things and this is stupid if it's true
and we need to hear from dak on this if
it's not true you know this can't be a
situation where a marketing agent or a
contract agent tells somebody off the
record there weren't more than 10 people
there and they were socially distancing
when we see the evidence from the TMZ
photos that suggests otherwise we need
to hear from deck and we need to hear
from the league on this this is unsafe
behavior we see how the draft has been
specifically engineered to comply with
the stay at home orders and the NFL has
been silent on this I asked the NFL
about it's Saturday night and I have
gotten no response and that's how they
deal with me when they don't want to
deal with me Chris they ignore me and
they make me ask again
and then they ignore me and they make me
ask again and I either quit asking and
write what I'm gonna write and everybody
gets upset at me or I keep asking until
they give me an answer and I'm just
gonna keep asking until they give me an
answer because saying we encourage
compliance isn't enough when it's clear
that people aren't compliant all right
let's take a break I feel better now I
don't know why this is controversial
we're talking about life and death here
that is not hyperbole this is real that
this is not something anybody should be
upset about that we are pointing it out
and I really would like Chris more
people in the media to set aside their
desire to have access and good
relationships and be willing to call it
like it is because lives are on the line
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports